sorry I haven't made a video in a while
I haven't died or been in exile I've
just been working on my next big project
myself don't worry this isn't a cry for
help I deal with things in private now
like everyone else and while I've been
known to bare my soul for views and
likes that's taken its toll though I
stand here today this is not me that
charlie is too messy but you love to see
instead you get the me I think you'd
like me to be the smiley guy who loves a
good cup of tea but if I'm just playing
a me that you know what happens in
private when I start to grow I might try
to catch up but the person you see just
gets further and further away from me
I've been painting this picture of me
for so long that though I am still here
my subject is gone and so now all that
remains is this image of someone that
you used to know but who left long ago I
want to get naked figuratively I want to
show you some truth you don't get to see
but the role of myself is tiring to play
the only reason that I'm here today is I
finally felt like I had something to say
and so now I perform fuel as myself
though I know it's a test of my mental
health I'm aware that this will make me
sound old but I feel for these new kids
who all have been told that to share
your whole self with the world is okay
because what happens to you when the
world gets to say oh it's funny he's
smart he makes wonderful art he's
talented young and he has a good heart
so be all those things for as long as
you can because as soon as you slip then
you've changed man now I have a great
life I have a nice split I love my
girlfriend I love my cats I'm aware that
these pains are a privilege to bear I
just want you to be aware that I gave so
much of myself I forgot where the public
me started
the privately stopped he hasn't posted
online in a while I wonder if he died so
is the worth of my life dependent on
whether I'm present online or I hide
value yourself by the comments you've
read even if they might just be a joke
and you'll wonder at that time you dyed
your hair red had more worse than the
words that you spoke the solution simple
don't give a fuck am I not supposed to
swear well that's tough if words of what
caused me to swim or to think that I
need to care less about what you think
you can say that I'm gone you could say
that I'm dead because I know I am still
working just offline instead if you just
value someone when they're on your
screen you assume they're a failure if
they go and see my absence does not mean
that I want to flee just that I don't
want all of my work to star me I'm still
human of course I still want to be liked
but not if that means that you like me
despite my means to like myself too and
that is why I withdrew again sorry that
it's been a while I've been busy
rebranding finding my style I'll be
posting new vids every day from now on
and then just like that he was gone